All right. Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to our session about
FLAME, which is a national federated learning consortium
intended to advance privacy-preserving oncology AI
through foundation model adaptation. My name is Julie Klemm.
I'm the acting director for the Center for Biomedical Informatics and IT at the
National Cancer Institute, and I'll be the moderator for today's
session.
Here's the agenda and speakers for today.
To start the session, I'm going to give a brief overview of federated learning and
introduce you to the FLAME project.
And the next speaker will be Shannon Silkensohn.
Shannon is a health science administrator at NCI CBET's
Clinical and Translational Research Informatics Branch.
And Shannon's going to describe the infrastructure, the capabilities, and
the governance of the FLAME Consortium.
Then next will be Umut Topaloglu. Umut is chief of CBET's
Clinical and Translational Informatics Branch.
And Umut is going to describe efforts to fine-tune the MedGema
model across cancer centers in the consortium.
Joining Umut as a late-breaking and exciting addition to
our panel is Ghulam Rasool from the Moffitt Cancer Center,
who's one of the members of the FLAME Consortium.
And then our final speaker will be Rakesh Khanna, who's a bioinformatics
scientist at CBET, who's going to tell you about his work to put the
FLAME network into action towards predicting overall survival
in glioblastoma patients using MRIs.
And we hope to leave time for Q&A at the end of the
session.
Here are our disclosures.
So I'm going to start by talking about why the NCI is
exploring the use of federated learning and how we got started with the
FLAME Consortium.
And FLAME stands for Federated Learning-based AI in
Multimodal Exploration.
So our interest in federated learning is really to overcome
challenges to better harness the use of AI to improve cancer
research and patient care. As I'm sure you all know,
strong AI models depend on access to large,
diverse, and representative data sets.
And that's where we run into challenges.
Cancer data are spread across hospitals and research centers,
and legal and regulatory and competitive barriers
often make it difficult to share these data.
But we need broader access to it to realize the promise of
AI.
For example, rare cancers and specific subtypes may
only exist in small numbers at any one site.
And in many data sets
underrepresent
important groups, for example, rural patients or minority
populations.
Another issue is that models trained at a single institution often
don't perform well elsewhere because patient populations and
clinical practices can differ significantly across institutions.
So federated learning offers a potential way forward.
Instead of moving data to a central location, it allows
us to bring the model to the data for training, enabling
collaboration across institutions while keeping sensitive
information secure and local. And in doing so, this
opens the door to learning from broader, more diverse data sets
and creating AI models that are more robust and generalizable.
So let me walk you through how federated learning works at a high level.
Federated learning starts with initializing a global model on a central
server, and this model is the basis from which the
federated learning process begins.
This model is provided to each of the sites in the network.
Now, each institution keeps its data locally and trains that
model on its own data.
The data could include clinical records, imaging, genomic
data, depending on the task.
After a round of training at each site, instead of sharing raw
data, each site sends only the model updates,
essentially what the model has learned, to a central coordinating
server.
And this server aggregates these updates to create an improved global
model, which is then sent back to all the participating
institutions. And this process can be repeated multiple times,
allowing the model to learn from a much broader and more diverse data
set, again, without the data ever having to leave its original
location.
And so the federated learning enables collaboration
across institutions,
ideally improving model robustness and helps protect patient
privacy.
So to explore the feasibility of federated learning across cancer
centers, the NCI initiated the FLAME Consortium in
2003.
The original goals of the FLAME Consortium were really proof of concept.
Specifically,
testing whether sites could exchange a model and federate using
a common technical infrastructure and governance approach.
The founding FLAME sites were the NCI,
CHOP, and OHSU in 2003.
In 2004,
we added University of Hawaii, Moffitt Cancer Center, and Wake
Forest. And finally, in 2005, two more sites
joined, UT Health Houston and Medical University of
South Carolina, bringing us to eight total sites in the FLAME Consortium.
So with that, I'd like to now hand it over to Shannon Silkensohn, who'll tell you
more about the consortium's infrastructure and governance.
Thank you so much, Julie. I'm really delighted to share with you all a little bit
about the operationalizing our network for federated learning.
I'm going to focus on three things: the infrastructure, the capabilities,
and the governance. This is really the meat of the talk.
You guys look up, get off your phone.
You're going to love it when I get to governance. All right.
So what makes this collaboration novel?
So traditionally, everything sort of happened sequentially, right?
You'd stand up some governance, you stand up some infrastructure, you'd get the
data together, you'd pull together a model, and this sort of linear
process took a really long time. So we said, "Hey, what if we
were to turn this on its head and just do everything all at once?" And so
we worked with different teams to stand up the governance, to work through
the infrastructure that is needed, and to gather the data sets.
And by working together sort of collaboratively all at once, we were
really able to condense the time probably down from 12 months to four
months, and it was really super great.
So
one of the things that's really important, and we've heard a lot about here is
about protecting patient privacy and patient data.
And so with federated learning, as Julie mentioned, the data stays
locally behind the institution's firewall. It doesn't leave.
So what does leave are these things called weights.
So if you have a model, there's different weights that are placed on the different
types of data, and they go into a secure place for aggregation, so that,
again, you can learn from patients that are all sites without the
data leaving the home institution.
So this is the good part. One of the things that was great about this
consortium is we set up a two-tier governance structure.
So the first tier was at the top, it was at the consortium level, and it had a
member agreement and bylaws. Member agreement is a super long
document. It has rules, responsibilities, publications, IP,
security. We could keep going, and this is what really gets signed by each
institution. We also put together a lightweight set of bylaws,
operational procedures about how to run an effective consortium.
The great thing is, once your institution signs the member consortium, you are part
of our team. You're a part of our family. It's amazing.
And then we set up this lower level of project governance.
And so this was at the project level.
So when you have federated learning, you have multiple sites, but not all sites
might want to participate in the same model.
So you set up this little transactional agreement between the two sites that want
to work together and collaborate data. It's lightweight. It describes a project.
You can do it really quickly. So speaking of describing the
project, one of the other things that we found to really help us
was we set up these model cards that had the technical specifications that were
needed for the model. How much data you need, what the
objective was like, what type of compute you needed to see if your
organization was really even able to participate and federate with
somebody else who was part of this team.
And as Julia said before, just to remind you, I don't know your level of
federated learning knowledge here.
So you have the different sites A, B, C, and D, and each of them
have their own data sets behind their institutional firewall.
You've got the central model. It gets shared out north, south, east, and west.
You aggregate it together to get the final model with the weight and the
contribution from all the sites.
So what's really cool about this is this infrastructure enables us
to create multimodal models in effect.
So you can take your imaging data, whether it's radiology or pathology, and you
can align it with your lab results and your clinical reports.
And when you bring this together in a model, you get a more comprehensive view of
the patient that, again, you're able to share across your institutions.
So in summary, I told you a little bit about the infrastructure that you need to
place, all of our capabilities, and last but not least,
two-tiered governance system. And with that, I'll hand the podium to
my friend and colleague, Dr. Topaloglu.
Thank you, Shannon, and good afternoon, everyone.
Thanks for coming to our panel. So I'll be talking a little bit about more
technical details about our implementation and shifting from why
and how we built to some of the clinical applications.
So the core tension here is most in the room may
agree that we know that getting patients into the right
clinical trial changes outcomes.
But the systems
make it incredibly hard to identify who is eligible
at the right
point of care of the patients.
And there are really four compounding problems that we see.
First, trials are chronically under-enrolled,
not because eligible patients don't exist, but because we can't
find them efficiently. Second, the data we need to make
that match is buried in unstructured texts
like pathology reports, radiology, progress notes, and so on.
Therefore, no structured fields tells cleanly some crucial
information needed for matching.
The third eligibility criteria are increasing the multi-model.
You may have seen increasing imaging findings and molecular
markers, and prior treatment history needed for
the matching. And we talk a little bit about some of the work
that we are doing at NCI about structuring eligibility criteria
yesterday's panel, and happy to talk afterwards if needed.
And the fourth is the obvious solution is training a powerful
LLM on that data that runs
directly into the privacy barrier.
We cannot just aggregate PHI across institution to
train a shared model easily.
Therefore, further learning is with the foundation model fine-tuning
is our way to get through that
barrier.So what you are seeing here is full
architecture end to end. On the left, each of our four participating
sites, as Julie listed those, has
its own local data, clinical text from EHR, radiology,
imaging from PACS, pathology slides and reports.
And each modality goes through its own pre-processing pipeline
before reaching the MedGamma. And we'll be talking a bit more
about the MedGamma itself. In the middle,
since privacy is important, you are seeing we have currently
differential privacy as one of the
model that
guarantees the privacy, but we are actively
investigating and exploring other privacy-preserving
methods that's not going to sacrifice a lot of...
or trade-offs from the model accuracy.
In the middle, again, there are options for aggregation that, I don't know if it's
readable, but like FedXLoRA,
FFA-LoRA, Heterogeneous LoRA, and
these are all different models that we are considering to
implement and potentially, for instance, a heterogeneous LoRA would be
great for
different computing environments that each cancer center may have
as availability of GPUs and other fine-tuning
computational challenges exist.
The result is
the
final federated QLoRA weights that each site can then use
locally for the task at hand. In this case, we'd
like to use for the trial matching.
So why MedGamma? So again, as for those who
don't know, MedGamma is developed by Google
and Gamma tree-based architecture, and the
advantage of it for us are two. One is it's openly
available. Google has put this into the public domain.
Anybody can access and fine-tune and utilize.
And it also
supports multi-model. Like you can see here, there are four
billion
version
multi-model text and imaging, 27 billion is text only,
and another
27 billion for richer clinical
representation. And as you can see in the middle, it can get
the imaging as well as some clinical data through FHIR
support with the new version that they have
released.
And
with that, I would like to invite Ghulam to talk about some of the
specific work that
he and his team working with other cancer centers.
Thank you, Ahmet. I'm Ghulam Rasul, an associate member in the
Department of Machine Learning at Moffitt Cancer Center, and we are
one of the sites which is contributing to the data, as well as we
are the aggregation server. So these are two
different roles, actually. So you have to set up an aggregation server separately,
then setting up ourselves as a site also.
So under the aim two of this project that we are implementing right now,
so we are fine-tuning MedGamma, as already
introduced.
So we have identified a retrospective cohort at each
site, which are lung and breast cancer patients.
It's retrospective data, and around we were aiming around 500
patients at each of the four sites.
And the idea was to use MedGamma out of the box
first to extract specific
information which is commonly found in
clinical trials on lung and breast cancer.
So,
one is out of the box, and then we will
fine-tune MedGamma
using QLoRA at each site.
And the third step will be actually doing a federated learning of the
QLoRA weights only.
So that's going to give us kind of a benchmarking of how MedGamma
works at each site out of the box, how MedGamma works
when we fine-tune it at each site, and do we
bring any additional value
when we train or when we fine-tune MedGamma across all four
sites? So when MedGamma has been exposed to
diverse data set from four different cancer centers and really
establishing the robustness and generalizability.
So, QLoRA, another question that we
kind of thought through was why not to just fine-tune
the whole MedGamma model, actually? Why QLoRA?
And the reason was that we wanted to start with something smaller,
where each site can first contribute,
with a smaller compute instead of updating the whole model.
And the second, we did not want to destroy the learning that the model has
already done. So these adapters allow us to freeze the
model weights and just add some new information.
So here is a kind of a more in-depth view.
And in the figure, you can see that
what we are trying to... How the QLoRA operates is it's going
to keep the model's original weights frozen,
and it's going to allow us to
define and then fine-tune a smaller
version of the weights, a reduced kind of a
matrix. And
we are still experimenting with different levels of hyperparameters.
This is just one set of hyperparameters that we tried.
Right now, out of the four sites, three sites
have fine-tuned,
benchmarked
MedGamma out of the box on their local
datasets.And also did the fine-tuning.
And federated runs are actually planned for this week, actually.
When we go back from ACR, we will be doing on Thursday and Friday,
we have scheduled our federated runs.
Here you will see from one site,
the effect of fine-tuning using local data only.
So these are the results from one site.
Blue is showing out of the box how MedGamma is able to
extract different
structured variable from pathology reports and clinical notes.
And the orange is after fine-tuning.
So we can see that
even with the kind of
smaller QLoRA weights, the model performance at
extraction of these variables significantly improves.
In a couple of other sites which have now completed this local
fine-tuning, in one of the sites actually,
the improvement is even more significant than what we are presenting
here.
So the next steps for us is to actually go now
to all four sites and do a federated run,
and which is going to add another bar here that how the
model is performing when we have done the federated learning.
And our hypothesis is that that QLoRA
fine-tuning is going to result in a more robust model
because the model has been exposed to the data
from four different cancer centers.
Thank you.
Thank you, Gulam.
So
despite this being very
great opportunity for using and fine-tuning
the foundation models such as MedGamma,
we are looking at the future and how we can ensure some
of the
challenges that a lot of you may be experiencing.
And clinicians, IRBs, and a lot of folks need to understand why
the model make a recommendation,
not just it is, yes, this patient matches
to this study. And as we are thinking about the
future, about how we can ensure that
interpretability, given that Gamma
3 based MedGamma platform, we are considering some
pilot projects around MedGamma Scope too,
because
these tools are the sparse autoencoders and
transcoders, and in practice, this will mean
that we can ask which clinical concept drove this trial match.
Was the BRAF mutation mentioned, the staging
information or the model actually picking up on
institution-specific phrasing that won't generalize?
I think we will be able to go deep down onto those type of decision-making
and for instance, as we mentioned briefly yesterday, knowing
each eligibility criteria, I think the interpretability layer
would allow us to go through.
So in summary, we are planning three specific capabilities, a
concept probe library for key oncology concepts,
behavior debugging dashboards that visualize
feature drifts across the federated rounds, and
continuous privacy auditing as these interpretative layers
would
tell us if the model remembers any of the identifiable
information from the trained data.
But we need to be transparent as roughly 20% of model behavior
may not be captured by these sparse autoencoders
and embeddings carry some immersion risks, and we are aware of this,
but we are constantly working, and if any of you have some ideas that
can contribute this approach, please let us know.
In conclusion, so
we are, as you have seen, federated infrastructure is live,
and all four NCI designated centers are connected using
NVIDIA FLARE and demonstrating PHI not
leaving the institution. Local, as Gulam mentioned,
local QLoRA fine-tuning of MedGamma is ongoing
and creating a meaningful increase in the accuracy.
So our next, as I mentioned, to focusing on the
interpretability layer to understand the model behavior
and also expand the network to include
other cancer centers. And
with that, I'm going to turn over to
Rakesh to talk about some of the
approaches that he has studied.
Thank you, Umit.
Today, in continuing this presentation, I'll be discussing a bit
about how we took a deep learning-based model for the
prediction of overall survival in GBM,
using MRIs,
and take a look at how we extended that model into
a scalable federated learning pipeline
through this FLAME collaboration.
Here are my disclosures.
And to kind of begin as a background, I wanted to talk
about prediction of overall survival in GBM more
generally using MRIs.
GBM, for those who don't know, is the most common and aggressive primary
brain tumor in adults, and it's characterized by
significant intratumoral heterogeneity, which can make risk
stratification quite challenging.And the
use of MRIs as a way to try to capture some
informative features early on in a patient's diagnosis
has been a topic of interest for some time.
And a kind of classical approach to this would be the very
popular field of radiomics, where
kind of handcrafted features,
maybe the volume of the peritumoral edema
or other kind of
statistical measures are used with simple machine learning
methods for predictions of overall survival.
But more recently, there's been a lot of excitement about the potential
for deep learning-based representations, either that
are learned with supervised learning or with
large-scale unsupervised pre-training to potentially
improve overall survival predictions.
And the potential utility of a model like this that provides risk
predictions at or near diagnosis could be used
as a baseline estimate of risk
in any evaluations for treatment changes beyond the standard of
care.
For a very well-trained model,
high-risk patients could be considered for
neoadjuvant or additional adjuvant therapies.
And additionally, for these high-risk patients, more frequent monitoring could
be enabled than the standard of care currently dictates.
And if you're interested in learning more about the potential clinical
utility, I'd highly recommend the AI-RANO
review in "The Lancet Oncology."
So now on to the federated learning aspect.
I think this question is particularly well-suited for federated learning
for a couple different reasons.
Firstly, GBM is a relatively rare disease with a
relatively low occurrence and data that is siloed
across the country and across the world in specialized
institutions.
Additionally, with the data that we're using, which is primarily MRIs,
there are varying scanners and field strengths
that cause a lot of site-specific heterogeneity,
which leads to the conclusion that no single institution can
capture the full scale that we'd like to see.
And that's true more broadly for deep learning, but I think particularly in this
case,
which leads to federated learning as a potential solution.
For the actual data sets that we used in this experiment, we used three
public GBM data sets,
plus a private data set collected by our colleagues at the Moffitt
Cancer Center who are here today.
And this is not a curated research data set, but
rather real-world data collected through routine clinical
care at the Moffitt Cancer Center.
And that added 104 additional patients to our analysis.
In keeping with the site-specific heterogeneity that I
mentioned before, we decided on a leave one site out
evaluation scheme, testing how does a model perform
without any site-specific fine-tuning.
Now, transitioning a bit into the actual model that we used.
We start on the left here with our structural MRI modalities,
specifically preoperative images, and we extract a region of
interest at each training step from these larger image
volumes.
The goal of that is threefold. We are focusing the scope of the
model onto tumor regions. We are
matching the pre-training shape, which I'll get into in a second,
and also augmenting the data set
to hopefully avoid overfitting.
The actual feature extraction that we used was a
sliding window vision transformer, which takes those regions of
interest and extracts features from each of them,
which after pooling, results in a fixed length
feature embedding of 768 features that
describe our series of MRIs.
And as I alluded to before, we're using a pre-trained encoder,
in this case,
from model weights from a model called the Brain SegFounder,
which was pre-trained on a large set of healthy participant
brain MRIs and MRIs from patients with
gliomas in the BRATS Challenge data set.
And the goal of this is to provide the model with as good of a starting
point as we can for our adaption to overall survival prediction.
This is something that's very popular in the broader field of deep learning,
but I think it's particularly important in federated learning, as
having a strong, centralized starting model is important for
training stability.
We can then take these pooled embeddings and using a classifier
of our choice, in this case, a multilayer perceptron,
make a single prediction of risk that can be used for relative
comparisons between patients and across cohorts.
Those risk scores can also be combined with other modalities,
but I don't have time to get into that in depth today.
So now moving on to the actual federation of an existing model like that.
We can, with nvflare, quite easily take
the centralized model that I talked about in the previous slide, along
with a standard PyTorch loop,
and extend nvflare's Executor class, which
has a few methods
that we need to divvy up the PyTorch loop into
in order to allow federation.
And this Executor class handles a couple of thingsIt
handles the receiving of the incoming model from
the federated server, handles the running of local
computation, and then at each site, it packages up those results
and sends them back to the server.
So
the key, I guess, here is that while there is a bit of a learning
curve to nbflare,
taking a model that is already made in PyTorch
and making it federated is quite easy with the tools that we
have available in nbflare. And as new
encoders come out, we can quickly switch them out
as the state-of-the-art evolves.
Here's the actual diagram for the setup that we used for this experiment.
I know that we've gone through a couple similar diagrams in the talk,
so I won't repeat everything shown here, but I just wanted to
highlight a few things. On the right, we have the
two clients
or two sites that we used for this experiment.
The NCI site in green housed the public data,
and the Moffitt Cancer Center site
connects directly to the Moffitt HPC resources.
On the left, we have in the blue the federated server, which handles
some of the message authentication.
In our case, we added early stopping monitoring and site drift
monitoring, and also housing of the global model.
As a start, we used the federated average
aggregation method, which is a standard baseline for these
methods, but we're looking at other aggregation approaches as well.
And the kind of main thing I want to talk about on this slide is that
we hope that adding additional institutional collaborators through this kind
of structure is as easy as possible.
As Dr. Sokinson mentioned,
we hope to provide tools for administrative onboarding
and also tools for technical onboarding through this
client startup kit.
So all that's really needed for the addition of a new
site is, or at least on the technical side, is the
provisioning of a client startup kit, which handles secure
connection with the federated server
through the certificates and keys,
some model configurations, and a startup bash script that
needs to be run in order to make the connection.
So now on to our initial predictions.
As I mentioned before,
our model outputs relative risk scores for each patient that can be
used
on a patient level or to make these cohort-wide stratifications,
as seen on the right, where we saw fairly consistent Kaplan-Meier
separation across each of the left out cohorts.
And we also collected a couple of metrics, specifically time-dependent
AUC
at one-year mortality and C-index, which tells
us the performance over the entire observation period,
which we found were consistent with prior work
in centralized settings
for this same question or similar question.
That said, I think these results are maybe not at the level that would support
clinical decision-making as is. But I think it's important to
emphasize that this is based on a single time point
preoperative MRI that has obvious limitations when it
comes to especially long-term prediction power.
So I think there's a lot of opportunity in terms of...
And it's certainly a lot of recent publications
in terms of the integration of additional modalities,
also potentially longitudinal data.
And for this project, specifically,
building on this work through more collaborating sites.
In line with those kind of points, we're currently exploring
and actually got the green light to go ahead and incorporate an additional
private GBM cohort from our NCI clinical center.
And we're also planning expansions for including radiology
reports, other imaging types that maybe will tell us more about the function of the
tumor, and additional clinical markers, which from our
initial tests have shown great synergy.
Overall, our conclusions are that so far we've been able to add an
additional 104 patients to this analysis without any data
centralization. This is fully real-world data
taken from Moffitt's standard of care.
And thanks to the transactional agreements, adding to this project has been simple.
Thank you, and here are our acknowledgments.
Okay. Thanks to all our panelists.
So just to wrap up what you've heard today before we go into some questions.
I think you've seen, based on this early work, that FLAME
is showing that federated learning at national scale
is really becoming operational through this infrastructure.
We've been able to bring together eight institutions total,
subsets working on different projects, showing that having the governance, the
infrastructure, and the AI development,
these activities can move together.
Again, as you've heard, federated learning allows
data to stay local and allows collaboration in ways that
might not be possible with centralized data.
We've seen evidence of foundation models improving with federation, both with
the MedGema example and the GBM example.
And I think as we can talk about more maybe in the Q&A, governance
really is part of the infrastructure, and having these reusable
member agreements and transaction agreements really
help make rapid expansion of this network possible.
So we are interested in continuing to expand this network, and if
your institution works in oncology AI and is interested in
collaboration, please do reach out to us.
We'd be interested to speak with you.And with that, I think we
have some time for Q&A. So we welcome questions from the audience,
and I think we have a few questions to kick off the conversation
today.
I think, Umut, you talked about privacy and federated learning, because that really
is a cornerstone of why to pursue federated
learning, where the data stay local-
Mm-hmm
... and the privacy is preserved. But as you alluded
to, there is risk of model inversion.
And can you talk more about
really where we are state of the art there, and what those risks are?
Sure. Yes. Unfortunately, despite the promise of data
staying local,
some research has shown the risks around the leakage, unintended
memorization, and also model inversion
type of attacks shown. So we have been
actively looking and working with others who have been
researching in this area, and most recently, we have
shown on an imaging data modality a model
using some transformations that can resist the model inversion
attack on both black or
white hat type of attacks. We have shown promising.
So right now, we are finalizing
approach that will potentially be working with other federated
learning networks as well. So we are not there yet that we
can certainly say it is awarded, but I think there are very promising
result that we can hopefully show very soon.
Thank you. And if any other panelists want to comment.
I think I'd maybe just also add that within federated learning, a lot of
these security measures can be tailored to the specific needs
of a site that would otherwise not be available
in a centralized setting. So if one site decides they would like a
larger amount of differential privacy or certain
security settings active for their gradient updates, that's
completely possible and actually baked into the
design.
Thank you.
Yeah, Martin.
Will you guys be versioning your adapters so if I join next year, I
can
run samples through and come back with comparable results?
You mean the QLORA adapters?
Yeah, yeah. The low-rank adapters.
So I think, I
will let Gulam to answer as well. The way we are looking is to pick
the different tasks and start fine-tuning foundation
model for different tasks, like the clinical trial matching is one example.
And there are some discussion internally around adverse event,
whether we can utilize these models for adverse event.
But we are seeing this mostly on the continuous learning because there
is always new data coming, right? Gulam, please chime in
what your opinion is.
Yeah, so from more technical side, we do use weights and biases,
so all the models that we are training are actually being versioned.
So fine-tuned adapters will be available for you to
come and test
different versions of those models.
So we talked about bringing new sites in, and so maybe it's worth talking about
what does it really take to join the network?
What level of effort should a site anticipate?
What resources, what time,
really should be brought to bear? And I think there's both kind of legal
governance considerations and technical considerations.
So maybe I could ask the panelists to comment on that.
Shannon-
I'll start
... would you want to start from sort of governance perspective?
Sure, Julie, I'd be happy to start.
And so from a governance perspective, there's really sort of two documents.
There's the member agreement, which is signed by your department's legal or your
institution's legal department, and then there's also the bylaws that you're made
aware of. And then sort of the second piece is the technical piece,
so you need to have the NVFlare server and certain sort of requirements so
that you can run the model at your site.
Do you want to build on that?
Sure. And on the NVFlare, there are three
clouds
currently being utilized across eight nodes that we have discussed.
Those are Google, AWS, and Azure.
So
I think with the available installation guidelines, it's
relatively straightforward.
So it's very easy to reach that barrier once there is commitment.
Of course, the legal agreement, we are aware that some
institution legal departments, due to the fact that the privacy
risk that we briefly discussed,
is a little bit of hesitant. But therefore, we are currently trying
to focus on the privacy and what is the
optimum level of the privacy guarantees that they feel comfortable.
Mm-hmm.
So that is an ongoing discussion, but happy to discuss
ideas that anybody may have.
Umut, you reminded me. We also put together a two-page document, which
just sort of describes the technology for lawyers,
which you can take to your legal department to say, "Here are
some sort of lay answers to some of the questions that you may have in terms of
privacy."
Gulam, did you want to add on?
So yeah, I just wanted to add that NVFlare does support
hybrid
architecture, which means that if one site is using AWS
EC2 instances, the second have GPU
available on premise, the third is using
GCP, that is exactly the architecture that we are using, and we are still able
to federate and do the federated learning.
So that is actually there. But of course, the challenge is
going to be that
each run is going to be dictated by the slowest site.
So it may take more time, but yes,
if you have any
compute resources available, you should be good to join those.
If I may add to that, I think you brought a very good point for those technical
folks in the room. Yes, the slowest training could slow down
the training, but NVIDIA FLARE has recently come up with some
model that will allow you to asynchronous
training, right? Let's say MAFIT with several GPUs
available might be completing five epochs while another
institution completing one. So there are some methods that will allow you
to do this asynchronously. So there are a lot of options.
Therefore, we would like to do this collectively with all the cancer centers.
Great point.
Yeah, Adam.
So full disclosure, we're one of the teams that had the privilege of working on
this amazing project. I'd love maybe for you guys to comment on two things.
One,
I know you asked about what are the challenges, and at least for us as
a pediatric-focused entity, I think one
challenge is to get data to that location
that you're going to operate. And I wonder if you guys can comment on that piece.
And then the second part
that I'd love your thought partnership on is, there's one component
around
talking about the federated learning framework.
But the second part that at least we see as a challenge is how do you intersect a
federated learning architecture with a clinical
trial framework where you actually do need the flow of
data
into a common architecture to track patients?
So how are you thinking about this intersection between a federated learning
framework, let's say you do
leverage it for clinical trial matching, but then the next question, okay, so now
this patient is enrolling in a trial.
What's that infrastructure and how does it intersect with the federated learning
framework?
Great questions. Who would like to start?
Let me start and please others chime in.
So the first part of the data, yes. Unfortunately, federated
learning is not a magic wand that addresses, right?
If you are running a federated learning network or any other type
of AI initiative at your institution, you
are limited or challenged by the availability of the good
quality and/or annotated data set, right?
Unfortunately, that's an ongoing issue.
As a matter of fact, CAIA, another federated learning network, they have
been focusing from the data perspective with
talking to the institution leadership and
make data available. So we have been in discussion with them.
So given that our approach is more, here are the models, let's see
what these research groups can do, while they are focusing more on the
institutional. I think those we see as complementary approaches,
and hopefully we can
do some joint collaboration with them to address some of those.
But ideally, if we can make our dream
state as-- or moonshot, as we call it, can we bring all these
72 cancer centers together to establish an NVIDIA FLARE
node, then our focus will be onto these data and make
these data available to these
nodes. I think that's focus
currently we have. I don't know anybody wants to add to number one, then we
can talk about the number two.
With respect to number two,
we don't see the federated learning being
only solution, right? We are aware that the hybrid solution, like
our CCDI initiative, they centralize data, and it
has its own use. And the model that we would
like to use with the FLAME, the fine-tuning, as a
matter of fact, currently we are discussing with the CCDI leadership, can we
take advantage of the centralized data to fine-tune the model?
Then if you are using sarcoma where there are four or five
pediatric patients at each site, there are some challenges,
even like how are you going to fine-tune with four patients at institution
A? We are aware of that. Therefore, there are a lot of potential of having
this centralized, and there are different models that we are thinking and would
love to hear. But the point is, can we help at
each site if we talk a little bit more on the
clinical trial site aspect of these initiatives, can we
have these foundation models fine-tuned for your study?
Let's say you are running a myeloma study,
and we'll be able to get data fine-tuned foundation
model for that study that extracts data, maps, annotates,
validates, and ships to
the analysis center. And then downstream, we'll be able
to use that data potentially to design new and more innovative
studies, right? So I think we need to think about this hybrid
solution where centralization has its own validity
and use, and federation has complementary.
Great. Next question.
Hi. Yeah, this is extremely pertinent discussion, to utilize
all the data sets that we generate and not waste a significant amount of them.
So I have a quick question. I don't have too much experience in federated learning,
but I've done some amount of survival modeling.
So I was just wondering,
so the Cox proportional or the Cox loss function
that you're using
for modeling the survival outcome,
so how do you essentially
account for the fact that you
aren't
taking into account all the at-risk samples
when you are trying to do learning in a federated manner?
Because compared to normal likelihood laws, when you use partial
likelihood,
you need the information about that entire cohort, which might be
what-- and that requires you to have information across all these
three
cohorts that you used, right?
I think I can answer that a little bit.
It's a great question. Definitely when we're using the partial log likelihood,
we're only kind of estimating within the batch that we use
for the Cox loss, since we're
optimizing for the negative partial log likelihood of the Cox
PH model.
So it's definitely an issue that we face, and
we're never going to get a perfect estimate of the entire cohort.
But in practice, when we're training these estimates
on smaller batches, can still kind of tend towards a
better overall model.
Okay. Do we have any estimate, let's say, for example, just
as a toy problem,
where you create artificial federations across such larger datasets?
Is there a way to
identify what kind of inaccuracies might arise due
to such approximations?
I haven't tried it, but I'd be very interested to-
Okay
... do that experiment with you if you're interested.
Okay. Thank you.
Please go ahead.
Hi. Thank you for this really informative session, and
congratulations on the effort. I was wondering if you have any similar
plans for basic cancer and pre-clinical research
data, like have a federated effort of a similar
scale?
Yeah. Maybe you can talk about how you onboard new projects.
How does a new project come about, in this case, say, a basic
research project? How do those get proposed and
socialized across the network?
Sure. I'd be happy to tell you about that, and we'd love to have you and your
organization join our network.
So the easiest way, I think, is to reach out on the website. We have a link.
And then, also, just we can talk through what the technical and what
the legal requirements are and what datasets and what projects you want to
propose, right? Because this is a consortium and a group.
So everybody comes with data and models and we'd love-
It's not specific for disease model research?
No, it's not specific. Yeah.
So again, we just want to establish this infrastructure
for ideas like you are mentioning to be able to
utilize. If you want to collaborate, let's say,
Gulam at Moffitt, you don't go through a legal for respective
institutions, which is taking a lot of time and unfortunately turning
a lot of folks away or discouraging folks from
working on their... The real challenge, as Adam mentioned, is the
availability of data. That's one of the bigger challenge that I think we
as community need to focus more than dealing with these
legal, administrative, and this infrastructure
point. So in summary, we are open. We are expecting people to come
with their idea, "Hey, we want to run." Even NCI doesn't need to be involved.
You can
talk to MUSC, Moffitt, or other centers to
establish a transactional agreement and run.
Transactional agreement is open to set the expectation
from each institution. Therefore, it's important.
Not necessarily NCI is requiring it. Again, we don't need to be part of it.
The reason NCI is not-- as you may know, we have
intramural research,
and there are a lot of great science going on within the NCI, and
they're also suffering similar challenges that many of you are,
availability of the sample size, right?
Our idea of putting NCI as a note is, can we
have our internal researchers work with the other cancer
centers, some of the innovative projects.
So
please come with the project ideas. We'll be happy to support as much as we can.
Yeah. Thank you for the great talk and good initiative.
A question building on that, what is kind of the scope of institutions that you can
see being part of FLAME, right? So you talked about NCI,
but yeah, beyond that, academic industry,
what's the scope that you're envisioning ultimately?
Good question.
So let me give a stab again. So
would've been great to have the moonshot goal would be having 72
and also probably going beyond the 72 community oncology
centers who may not have a lot of expertise or computing
power as well to join this and would be great to
help the cancer centers if
biopharma or other initiators because yes, NCI funds a lot
of research, but we are not the only ones, right?
There are a lot of studies going through the pharma and other
private industry, and it would be great to have this federated
network be used for both NIH and
CI-funded research as well as the pharma.
I hope I'm answering your question.
I think our goal is to make it available freeway
for any cancer research to take place among those centers.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Maybe I'll ask a follow-on question.
Are the governance documents, member agreements, are they
very generic to any kind of institution, or were they really envisioned for
academic institutions?
Yeah. Julie, so that's a really good question.
They're meant to really be a starting point or a starting base because when
we started, we didn't really have anything to work from, and so we thought, "Well,
this is a gift that we can give to the community." And so they're up on our
website. Take them, make them yours, sort of add some pieces, take
some pieces out. But what we hope is they really have some
good bones to them and definitely have some of the required pieces of
legalese that needs to be there.
Matt Shabath, Moffitt. Terrific session, by the way.
It's too bad there's only a handful of us missing out on really an
important area of research that is absolutely next generation
that everyone should be adopting.
I'm really
excited about the clinical trial work that Machin you're doing
Lot of questions about that, but one is, how are you going to actualize this?
Are you reaching out to the cooperative groups, SWOG, ECOG?
To me, that would be a great test bed once you really get this
performance working well,
obviously doing this in parallel with
real humans, making sure we're not dropping the ball.
But I think the cooperative groups would be a great place for this to
operate as a proof of principle. And I guess a
second question is, I'm not sure, what are your next steps?
You've shown how you can extract data.
You've got various performance for certain
variables. All our cancer centers have completed
hundreds and thousands and thousands of clinical trials.
One thing is just go pull retrospective trials
and how well does this work? Does it capture everyone?
And who didn't it capture? Who did it capture that was not included?
So I'd love to hear more about the clinical trial matching work.
Sure. So great point, and of course, as you laid out, there
are several challenges that we are trying to address with our
colleagues at the cooperative groups.
So one of which is,
we mentioned yesterday's session where we talked about some of
the protocol activation challenges and how we use AI
LLMs for that challenge,
including the eligibility screening.
But we are aware that our cooperative groups,
Alliance and others, are also working on
some similar initiatives. Right now,
after discussing with the
CTAC leadership, we have decided to connect with each of these groups to
identify their... So it's a slow-moving process, but
we recently started contacting the groups
to find out what they are doing and also share some of the work
like this to be shared. But as you can imagine, there are
multiple components needs to happen to scale this
up, right? We need to have this structured eligible criteria
ready and as well as the EHR data
standardized, map the USCDI plus cancer, if possible.
Then we'll be able to validate and scale easily.
Otherwise, right now, still... And the interpretability layer that
I mentioned is towards that goal, how we can
show
the inner workings of this process of these models so we can
convince Alliance, SWOG, NRG, and everyone, as well as
our cancer center colleagues and physicians.
So
we are slowly moving,
but we are trying to get there.
Well, and I think what I hear you saying, Umut, is there are many parallel
exciting initiatives happening that could all come to bear on, I think, what you're
saying here. And so I think what FLAME is
showing is really the feasibility of being able to federate.
And as these additional capabilities come on board, the power of
the federation
may be exponential ideally.
I just want to add one thing. So Matt, the third aim of
our project is actually... So second aim is
on MedGema fine-tuning, and the third aim is
actually
to validate it on some of the clinical trials that were run on
all four cancer centers. So we do have a plan right now, but
it's very small. We just wanted to maybe test on
30 patients only, kind of just showing the feasibility
that if we do federated learning, we expose these type of models to data
from four different cancer center diverse dataset,
they do start performing significantly better.
And we'll do that in the third aim, and hopefully we'll establish
some benchmarks for next projects.
Thank you.
Well, if there are no further questions, I think we're at the end of our time
together today. So thank you all very much for joining.
If you're interested in learning more, I think our panelists may be available
afterward, or please do feel free to reach out and we'd be happy to talk more
about your questions and possible involvement. So thank you all very much.